[Music]
i see color as a form of communication
i feel like it tells a story when i look
at colors like in a painting i think
automatically can i put that on a head
my name is daniel moon and i'm a hair
colorist
i first started getting into hair when i
was in the marine corps
i barbered myself and other friends i
was granted permission
to exit the marine corps to go to hair
school
being so restricted in the military i
think getting out of it there were no
limits restriction was enforced on me so
when it came to creating i kind of vow
that i'd never restrict myself from
doing something that felt like i wanted
to do and somehow came up with this
magic way of coloring hair
so freehand hair coloring is looking at
the head as a canvas
whether it's short hair or long hair
being able to
just paint on it as if it was a
sculpture
i find inspiration everywhere i look to
the art world
i look to the
magazine world i look in books i look
where people don't think about looking
when i'm choosing colors and designs i
imagine like a checker board this
purpose here this thread is here can i
connect this color to that color i'm
looking at it from every angle top
bottom left right and then just playing
with those different kind of shapes
i don't think about being different from
other hairstylists i create work that is
different for me it's different from my
last piece
i think people dye their hair to have
fun
to create a persona that's fun to live
in
did some big color changes and had some
great collaborations with madonna
katy perry
nicole richie
and zoe kravitz
the work that i create is temporary and
that is
a romantic thing
because it fades away hair grows out
i can spend three hours
six hours on a piece and then i can walk
out the door and it's never seen again i
like that it's an art form that washes
away i like to just continue on creating
and just making something that i've
never seen before
you